you know all the people who said you'd
never make it and then you have a number
one song with see you again and you
wrote that for someone else in mind
right you were writing about a friend of
yours that uh I guess you had lost uh my
friend Vale who had passed away on he
died on the the Boston bridge going to
MIT the guy was in a car accident
yeah he got hit on by a car while he was
riding a motorcycle and kind of just
died instantly and a good friend very
very yeah my best bud fail and uh I kind
of uh two years later went to uh
California on cahuanga Boulevard at the
old death row Studios and they were
working on this uh this song it had
these chords which are the See You Again
chords but it had like this really
Cynthia like
it was a dance song because those were
really popular at the time these type of
rappy dance songs and we just kept
layering since we just kept adding [ __ ]
and adding [ __ ] and adding [ __ ] and it
wasn't really going anywhere and
there was I I was like okay I gotta
delete everything I'm a nobody I just
came from New Jersey but I got to delete
all this [ __ ] right now and instead of
hearing
I was like guys what if it was just
simple
and then just out of my mouth it's been
a long
because I was thinking about my friend
without you my friend and I'll tell you
all about it when I see you again and it
was basically that would be my message
to him if I had one more thing to say to
him before he passed away and you were
writing that with these guys ostensibly
to sell a song to somebody else right oh
we had 10 artists cut it we had Jason
Derulo cut it we had Chris Brown cut it
I think Adele wanted to cut it at one
point I think Eminem was on the line to
do it
um we had
countless
of artists uh do it but nothing felt
again going back to the theme of the day
going back to the feeling like how Bruce
writes his music it just didn't have
none of the vocals had like the feeling
they didn't go through what they might
have experienced some form of loss in
their own way but what I was singing
about specifically you just couldn't
hear it in their voice I think Chris
Brown got the closest to it but it was
they ended up Lucky Lucky Me going with
my vocal but then there was all this
drama like oh who's this kid on YouTube
singing covers he can't sing for Fast
and Furious it was a whole mess and I I
remember the I got to the day of the the
day of the video shoot I got there and
they were like you're not on the song
anymore so I went home but then I
suddenly was on the song again so they
added another [ __ ] day to the video
so I had to go back and that's why it
was it was what is
what is a number one song but I had to
work backwards for a really long time
and the weird thing is you were the
writer of the song and look at the
struggle like you wrote that song and
you still struck the record yeah wrote
and produced the record and I'm still
I'm still figuring out how to be an
artist